well join me now is the author and come
and say to Angelica Mallet talk to these
Esther Krakow and Fox News contributor
Tommy Lowe and so Tommy layering let me
start with you two two people in Britain
today
who've been at the Forefront of not
saying what a woman is one is Nicholas
sturgeon the ex first minister of
Scotland who lost her job because of
this ridiculous fast of a rapist
self-identifying
um she tweeted at a proud and
international women's day to visit my
old University of Glasgow and banged on
about women's rights this is the woman
who just literally lost her job for
allowing a male rapist into a female
prison and Sakira starmus literally the
opposition labor party here was talking
about protections for women in
Parliament today and yet he refuses to
say what a woman is
where are we with this how has it come
that leaders of parties in countries
like the UK and you see a lot of it in
America as well just won't say what a
woman is
well first of all I have to apologize to
you because all of this wokeness
originates here in the United States of
America and then we export it to you in
the U.S yes we started this really in in
America yes we are you know the wokeness
starts here and then it of course moves
over and now you guys have to deal with
it the world has to deal with it but I
say this I'm proud to celebrate
International women's day because I know
what a woman is so I would say if you
don't know what a woman is you don't get
to celebrate it you don't get to pretend
to be a feminist when it's helpful to
you or helpful to your political
narrative you have to be able to Define
what a woman is this is all of farce
they are seeking to erase women and this
is the radical rainbow Mafia as I call
it this is not your average LGBT
activist this is the rainbow Mafia
section of that radical lgbtq movement
that has made women less than and then
has elevated all of this transgenderism
and all of this pickier gender identify
as potato they have hijacked the women's
rights movement the feminist movement
and actual feminists should be really
pissed off about it well as a feminist I
am um I recently interviewed Angelica
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak and I
asked him this question which seems to
stump many other leaders here's the clip
what is a woman
we know that Nicholas sturgeon can't
answer that we know kirst armor can't
answer that you're the British prime
minister what is a woman yeah I of
course I know a woman adult human female
it's not difficult is it Angelica I mean
that is what a woman is I mean I don't
know why you're obsessed with defining
it like what what is a man like why do
we need these arbitrary a man is a male
adult human I mean that's it right okay
I don't know that we need these are just
biological facts but they're just facts
they're not they're not arguable points
are they but you I think we have a right
to self-identify and you said you want
to as well I'd like to be a woman you
can identify as a woman I don't know why
there is such an issue around we've
literally just seen a male rapist use
that scam to get himself put into a
female prison where he could attack
vulnerable women inside a female prison
when even his ex-wife said it was all a
scam which is a terrible very
distressing isolated incident and I
think it's easy to take that and say
that means that no no one can identify
as a woman
but it's it's 42 of trans identifying
prisoners in prison are in there for sex
crimes there's actually an advantage
evidently to identifying as a female
because they never identify as male
because somehow milk doesn't seem less
appealing to them it's really weird
anyways this self-identity
totally Limitless when you're talking
about International women's day I don't
know why we take the the conversation
around International Wednesday and make
it about this but if anyone has so many
best but if anyone according to you can
identify as a woman anyone can right
I don't see a problem just literally put
the hand up and say I'm a woman but it's
not an easy thing to do to go out that's
very easy you might think it's easy to
say but to decide to do that to say what
is it doing it involved whatever that
person decides and say I I don't
identify as perhaps the sex so why can't
I identify okay why can't I identify as
a black lesbian
well firstly I mean I'm serious I'm
serious if I can identify as anything
without any need to prove I'm actually
what that is I I why can't I on
International women's day say I'm Piers
Morgan I'm a black lesbian I think
taking it to a kind of absurd moment
with respect I think that you've already
opened the absurdity door by saying it
is Limitless you can do what you like
anyone can say I'm a woman so I simply
ask you why can't I I mean this point
kind of ridicules trans people to an
acceptance actually I think what you
said ridicules trans people because
actually people who who go through the
full process of transitioning who
actually go through what we used to call
a sex change which I don't think you can
Muck around with original biology but
those who actually go through surgical
procedure of them a number of years I've
got great respect for that very
difficult Journey they go on I have zero
respect for people who just Wallop their
hand up and go suddenly I'm a woman and
I want all the rights that a woman has
and I want to compete saying sport I'm a
foot four inch athlete Sprinter swimmer
whatever who's competed very
mediocreally in male sport I now want to
come in and Crush women in swimming
pools and in sprinting events and break
all their records perhaps irrevocably
just by saying I'm a woman I think that
is the absurdity you were talking about
my response was to say well if it's
Limitless why can't I then say whatever
I want to say and you say immediately as
I knew you would well that's ridiculous
but my point is you have been ridiculous
well that's your opinion you can think
I'm ridiculous but I don't think you can
say Well it has I don't know why I am
but you're not you're I don't think
you'll say it's post-op is the only way
that someone's allowed to identify the
original standard for us standard for
being transgender was being diagnosed
with gender dysphoria which is a
legitimate condition and now it's been
oh however way you feel so if you feel
on Tuesday you're a woman and on
Thursday you're a pizza that's perfectly
valid but to you that's ridiculous and I
want to know why that is ridiculous we
should be talking about actual women
national women's day that's not crazy I
mean I agree I think but your idea of an
actual woman is an adult female it's not
different chromosomes are a pretty good
indication I don't think you have to be
biologically female to identify then you
are wrong because then I can identify as
a fox
yeah but again it's kind of an absurd
Point how many well let me ask you this
let me ask you this Angelica how many
genders are there
two there are two genders oh wow so you
don't believe in transgenders at all
well I think I think whoa whoa whoa whoa
there are two genders well it's taught
well if you say well you've literally
just launched this huge defense of
transgenderism now you've eradicated it
I think there's there are two genders
you mean male and female right there's
gender fluidity I will fluid between
what between what between different
identities and we can choose you see how
difficult this is though but it is
difficult but I think maybe but it's not
difficult until you make it difficult
you see the BBC has done teaching videos
to 11 and 12 year olds where they say
there are a hundred genders one of them
was Astra gender which is an affinity
with the Stars on the Galaxy my response
to that on the last show I did was to
say well in that case it identifies a
two-spirit penguin I was then told I was
being ridiculous but I made the same
point the Ridiculousness is the BBC
teaching kids there are a hundred
genders there aren't it is absurd bring
back Tommy lahren who I imagine is
hyperventilating over there Erica
um Tommy I mean look I don't see why if
it's Limitless I can't just say I'm
Piers Morgan I'm a black lesbian because
that is where Limitless self-identity
takes this it means that male rapists
can say they're women and get into into
female prisons it means I can say I'm a
two-spirit penguin or a black lesbian
and why can't I because that is where it
takes you
well it certainly does and I think you
just had the perfect argument there it's
impossible to Define and it's impossible
to stand up for because it's a mockery
of what actual people are and
furthermore going back to children when
this happens at a young age when you
start trying to convince kids that they
don't know what gender they are they're
born in the wrong body at two three four
five six seven eight nine ten years old
that's child abuse all right gender
affirming care wherein you only tell
somebody they can be whatever they want
to be regardless of their biology at a
young age that is child abuse it's
happening in the UK it's happening in
the U.S and this is making room for
groomers to groom young people to
confuse the heck out of them make them
not know what they are so they can take
advantage and exploit them now I want to
be very clear here this is not the
mainstream lgbtq movement there are a
lot of conservatives that even support
that movement this is a radical agenda
made by groomers and they don't want you
to call them groomers which is a perfect
example of why they are groomers this is
what we're doing is to confuse young
people to confuse all people to make
them Dumber May make them confuse as to
what they are it's a mockery of women's
rights mockery of Human Rights yeah and
we should no longer be having and you
end up with scandals like the Tavistock
Clinic here in London in the UK where
they were basically mutilating children
young you know kids teenagers mutilating
their bodies irrevocably and then it
turned out after it closed after a
scandalous report came out but 97 of all
the patients had other conditions from
autism to depression to other issues
which may have been affecting their
ability to think straight about what
they wanted to be and that was to me as
a father of four kids utterly horrific
just horrific that this was going on and
anyone who tried to raise concerns about
this and journalists did were
immediately branded transphobic and
Esther this comes back to what we see
with you know people like JK Rowling
who's I'm no friend of Jackie rally she
can't stand me and I don't like her
right we it's like fire and water but I
on this issue I've not seen a word she
said that is transphobic I've just heard
her go I want to support and protect
women's rights for that she's been
unbelievably hounded abused attempts to
cancel which fortunately have backfired
but it's all wrong this isn't it the
thing is and one of the shocking things
that she's been attacked for is for
drawing attention to domestic violence
and violence against women and that's
actually the biggest Point here other
than the fact that you know that male
rapist was allowed to go into a female
prison in Scotland there's a genuine
danger about around allowing men into
women's spaces like women's shelters and
things like that and they can be there
just by identifying as a woman and then
identifying as a tree the next day right
so do you I mean do you understand that
part of the argument I understand that
kind of the argument but I I mean like
Tommy said I don't think this is
confusing for children I think it's
giving you freedom of expression and
freedom of choice how many girls did you
know like my wife was a bit of a tomboy
when she was young right how many kids
do you know young girls in particular
who are tomboys but if the wrong person
gets hold of them and persuades them
actually what you should start doing is
mutilating your body and have a full
attempt to become a boy that's not what
most tomboys end up wanting they end up
actually going through puberty getting
older and then that's it they've become
women right but if you get hold of these
impress young minds too early when
they're just Clowning Around being
tomboys that's the danger to me I don't
think the messaging is as Extreme as you
as you think it is and I think we it was
pretty extreme I think we whip ourselves
into a frenzy thinking uh thinking these
things and this language that you
mentioned at the start of the show I
don't think you hear that language used
that often in like everyday speech which
language I think what you were saying um
I know these are all NHS websites I know
this is where you're wrong this is
actually NHS websites in many cases they
genuinely call women chest feeders
birthing Partners they dare not say
anything gender specific to women in
case some trans people don't like it to
which I say where are the rights of
women to be called what they want to be
called why does all language have to be
degendered for a tiny minority of people
I think the problem is there's so much
fear around having these kind of
conversations and saying the wrong thing
getting it wrong that means that people
can't have conversations that feel kind
of progressive about what what is gender
identity what does the future look like
how do we create a compassionate space
so so I think to your questions start
like what is women and why politicians
wouldn't answer it they're so scared of
getting it wrong and I think it was
scared because they they gives the the
mob come for them exactly and the mob
needs to just go away and shut up anyway
I think scrap International women's day
until we can all agree what a woman is
no I'm sorry I think there's so many
benefits to having International women's
day it would be a real shame to do that
well if you're head your way everyone
was celebrated by identifying as a woman
even if they weren't well banglam happy
International women's day I am a woman
it's a false anyway Angelica lovely to
see you thank you very much I'm still
going to see you a bit later on Tommy
always good to have you over at the pond
International women's day there you are
a fine example of a genuine woman great
thank you yes absolutely identify as a
woman I am a woman and that's how this
thing works ladies and gentlemen exactly
thank you Tommy Lara